I'm sure now by dr. Donna Beach she's
director of policy and advocacy at the
Higher Education Policy Institute and by
anastasiya Duvall she's deputy director
of the think-tank Civitas anastasiya
store with you is it the fact that there
are a lot of people go to university for
questionable degrees and massing debts
on the back of it I think there are some
people doing that I think a lot of it is
about not being informed about options I
think that there is an emphasis that
only University is the route to success
and I think that's what we need to talk
about it I'm so pleased that you're
doing this on tonight are they talking
about higher education listening to
young people's views about it we need to
discuss the realities which is not to
say going to university as a bad thing
at all but we need to look at the
options and we need to look at the
courses see which ones are valuable and
see which ones are really going to set
young people up for the futures that
they want so we should really be asking
hard questions about the economic value
that they bring these course some of
these courses absolutely and just simply
the value is it going to be something
that you find stimulating I think the
main problem as I say is that there's a
sense that you have to go to university
if you're going to be successful we know
that there are lots of very successful
high profile famous people very
successful in their careers didn't go to
university but did for example in work
training routes now it's not about
saying one is better than the other but
it's about saying there are other
options and do scrutinize the course
that you're about to fork out a lot of
money for or odana let's bring you in at
this point what do you think of what to
Anastasia has just been saying I mean
basically we should be a bit more
questioning a bit more judicious about
sending half the population to
university good evening I would actually
disagree with that I think the value of
a university education is there for all
to see there are financial benefits so
Graduate earning potential I know men
can amp on average in a lifetime 170,000
pounds more and women that stretches to
20 sorry two hundred fifty thousand
pounds more but there's more benefits
than that as the cultural and social
ones that are often not spoken about as
well and you're not necessarily going to
get these if you go out to work and
these are things like going away from
home getting transferable skills living
with others it's not it's much more
about the subject that you study right
badami should the taxpayer necessarily
be paying for
to learn things like going out and
getting drunk and socializing don't
think going to universities about
getting drunk and socializing actually
one of the benefits shows that in later
life graduates are actually more
inclined not to drink not to be obese
and you know to eat healthily so
graduates actually have 8% higher life
expectancy Emma says you what do you
think of that I think it's about having
useful experiences obviously as becoming
an adult becoming employable and
actually I think it's interesting that
we're hearing a lot of employers saying
that graduates aren't necessarily coming
out with the skills that they want but I
think the other thing to say is not
going to university doesn't mean
stopping your education apprenticeships
and they are full programs good
apprenticeships
are very high quality you might go and
live elsewhere you will have colleagues
you will have an experience that you you
know what was it we're hearing about in
relation to the university experience so
I think that's the thing I'd really
encourage let's stop thinking about
universities the only way to be educated
later on there are actually in work
played training schemes but also an
apprenticeship is a continuation of
education it's not about just going
straight into a job and starting the job
and we've got to factor that in to the
reality and we've also got to give that
I think the necessary showing that it
requires for young people on Diana beach
that's a real issue isn't it I mean we
are now in a situation where because
we're sending half the country to
university a lot of jobs which
previously didn't require degree level
qualifications
now do yes that is true but I think as I
said before it's more about more than a
subject that studies it's about the
transferable skills and that comes with
the university experience and I think as
Anastasia was saying there are degree
apprenticeships now so that's sort of a
halfway house between earning and
learning and actually having the full
benefits at University experience
provides you with and as I said those
are the cultural and the social benefits
of living with others living away from
home and flourishing as a person Doni
men should just know the huge gap in
earnings I think you said a quarter of a
million pounds that a female graduate
can expect to earn over their working
life compared with a non graduate in
your view does that justify tuition fees
I think it does yes I think the personal
financial rewards does justify graduates
making back a contribution to what
they've borrowed but only if they can
afford to do so and at the moment that
is the current threshold is if they own
over 21,000 pounds we've got this big
Rao at the moment over the pay of
university Vice Chancellors is that do
you think some of them should be
volunteering for pay cuts to restore
confidence in in the higher education
sector I think personally in my personal
point of view subject to Vice Chancellor
pay levels is a matter for individual
universities and the magic of our higher
education system is its diversity and
the fact that we do have different types
of institutions some a local some a
global some bring in big revenue and
some specialize and you know not so
profitable subjects like the creative
arts so I think what the public need to
see is that their leaders are getting a
salary that is proportionate to the type
of institution that they are and also
the changes that are being made to this
institution and I think above all what
the public needs to see is that their
fair pay differentials between the
different grades and jobs for the new
University I lost what you anastasiya
very briefly should we be turning some
modern universities back into
polytechnics I think we need to have a
broader landscape when it comes to
higher education so that universities
can really do what they're best at so
that we have a breadth of skills and so
that students really have options I
think at the moment it's about not
having enough options and not being
well-informed enough